[Music]
this channel was deemed too dangerous
and harmful by youtube but unfortunately
we think it violates our harmful and
dangerous policy it's important to us
that youtube is a safe place for all if
the content breaks our rules we remove
it
content that encourages illegal
activities that's right our show is so
dangerous that we encourage illegal
activities we have permanently removed
your channel from youtube that's right
ladies and gentlemen boys and girls you
are watching the most dangerous business
show in the world right here live on
youtube the taliban is allowed on
youtube the ccp is allowed on youtube
but the most dangerous business show is
not we were de-platformed and it says
going forward you won't be able to
access
possess or create any other youtube
channels they said we think this is not
good on our platform and they would
were able to completely delete the
channel and de-platform us
we were de-platformed
sometimes you just got to be the
dangerous guys dangerous [ __ ] yeah
the fact that we got cancelled off the
platform is absurd we were de-platformed
they were tweeting at susan after i told
her to call me she didn't call dangerous
[ __ ] yeah they came for you john
censored yeah what's your job the most
dangerous
giving away cash free education got
censored though listen here we the
captain now we're the captain now you
don't d-platform us we de-platform you
dangerous [ __ ] yeah the only thing i'm
willing to accept from the youtube team
the only thing is put us on the home
page and give us another 250 000
subscribers then we'll call it even fair
trade fair trade
dangerous [ __ ]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
good morning good morning good morning
welcome back to the best business show
why is it the best simply because we
said so this is the show that my
brothers and i wish that we had when we
were learning about business investing
in finance i've got two of my brothers
here with me joe and john how do you
know their names are joe and john pretty
simple their names are on the back of
their chairs these guys are
real slow but a little fist bump ready
to go you guys ready we're ready bitcoin
still popping we're back lots to go over
today we're going to talk about
everything from etfs to breaking news
just happened the houston firefighters
uh public pension fund bought bitcoin
put on the balance sheet what's up
firefighters putting out fires putting
sound money in your pension fund
congratulations uh we also have bill
barheit the abra ceo he's gonna be here
in studio and then we have kevin o'leary
calling in a bunch of stuff to talk to
him about as well before we get started
don't forget the show is free the
content is free tired of talking about
it this is the deal you come here you
watch the show every day you press the
like button that's the entry fee when
you press the like button we give out
free stuff where 449 people watching or
i'm sorry likes right now on the count
of three one two three press the like
button we cross over 500 i'm gonna give
out let's start with maybe 150 bucks a
bitcoin today sounds good 150 of bitcoin
right now just crossed 500 on the count
of three go ahead and drop in the chat
your twitter handle john's gonna pick
one person right out of the gate we
literally we're like 30 seconds into the
show already 150 of bitcoin going into
someone's pocket that's how this show
works is it's free content you come here
you smash the like button people get
paid
learn laugh earn best show on the
internet also sofi
sofi.com if you are going to get into
investing if you're going to get into
your new life as to not be a consumer
spending wasting your money instead you
want to actually buy assets that go up
because the federal reserve and other
central banks around the world are going
to pump your bags then you should go and
use the financial products and services
that sofi provides gotta read the terms
and conditions there's always risk when
you invest lawyers maybe say it but go
to sofi.com
you can buy stocks you can buy bitcoin
cryptocurrencies you can refinance your
student loans your car loan your credit
cards etc go to sofi.com
make sure that you sign up for an
account if you put two thousand dollars
into the account bam you're in the
diamond hands club for the diamond hands
club that means that you get to come
hang out with us you get to come into a
private slack you get to do all the
private q and a's the private interviews
etc go to sofi.com
put two thousand dollars in the account
diamond hands club you in the club with
us what's up john i got the winner oh
who's the winner uh ken ankovich ken
anklovich you win
150 bucks and that's
i mean we're at 900 likes so we just go
should we just roll the tape another 150
dollars that's the life smash the like
button right now if we get to a thousand
i'll give out another 150 worth of
bitcoin that easy we'll just keep doing
this all day long it's just like
unlimited amount of free bitcoin flying
out here
because joe and john are paying today so
you know hey that's how this works so
unlimited today baby uh you guys just
keep it look at them laughing they know
an unlimited amount of bitcoin available
to be given out cards
hit him he's hot
oh a thousand likes perfect we're not
making people do this uh this time i
want you to drop your instagram account
or your twitter account either one no
questions no anything just if you drop
it into the actual chat we'll go ahead
we'll pick one person joe's picking 150
i love how like 50 people right in the
chat one k likes one k like they want to
make sure we know
we want to make sure we see all right
that's the deal keep hitting the like
button as we cross over every 500 likes
you know what happens we give out free
bitcoin someone made a good point it's
not unlimited bitcoin why can't one 21
million
don't worry joe and john probably come
up with some garbage ads
eventually when they run out of the real
stuff all right etf launched earlier
this week the pro shares bitcoin futures
etf absolutely came out smoking they had
in the first day 570 million dollars of
assets and over a billion dollars of
trading now after day two they ended
with more than one billion dollars in
total assets in the etf that is the
fastest start an etf has ever had the
previous record was held for 18 years by
gld the gold etf but of course bitcoin
how telling how ironic the digital gold
gold 2.0 coming out and absolutely
smashing the record gld did it in three
days bitcoin etf did it in two days so
one billion dollars in total assets
flowing into that asset now if we go
ahead and we look eric from bloomberg
absolutely crushing it this is the
bloomberg etf analyst super bowl they
have been over this all week they've
been all over it record breaker bito
assets up to 1.1 billion after today
making it the fastest etf to get to a
billion breaking gld's 18-year record
which is poetically appropriate if we
then go ahead and we look at the actual
charts that they're sharing there what
you can see is that bito destroyed this
is that little blue line on the far left
that's gld gld was on rocket ship when
it launched but of course b-i-t-o if it
was on this chart is much much better
now if we go ahead and we take a look at
a second tweet from eric he said if bito
keeps up this pace of inflows it won't
have any futures left to buy by the end
of the month due to the uh position
limits that they have so literally there
is so much capital that is flowing into
the bitcoin futures etf that at this
pace if it is persistent we'll wait to
see only two days in this day three but
if it continues they literally will not
have enough futures contracts to
actually buy in the market i have no
clue what happens at that point but i'm
willing to bet that the futures uh
individuals will definitely figure out a
way to serve that they'll feed the ducks
and some might say so how impressed are
we that there's over a billion dollars
that flows in and more importantly are
we surprised that it happened this
quickly no i look like people have been
starving for a kind of an institutional
investment vehicle for them to for them
to have access to so it's not really
surprising uh i think it's funny that
it'd be gold right to that limit uh but
it's not really surprising i think the
one thing that would be surprising is
right like no individuals or retail
traders are really buying this stuff the
best of my knowledge right like i don't
know the actual numbers on them but we
didn't buy it we advise other people not
to buy just go buy their own bitcoin uh
and own the asset themselves so i think
what's surprising is that there was just
so much pent-up demand from institutions
have access to this and yeah sure it's
not people that are all long-term uh
that are just long the asset class it's
individual traders and institutional
guys that are going in and uh trying to
make money on the asset but i think it's
surprising just from the pent-up demand
side john what do you think
two days is wild i don't think any
anyone ever thought that that gold
hockey stick when you look at how many
days it took to get to a trillion
dollars and or a billion dollars in
volume would be beat but no one's ever
seen an asset like bitcoin it is a
little bit surprising to me um as we had
the annual let's talk about how it would
take it would maybe get to like five six
billion over time um but a billion in
one day is is pretty surprising to me i
actually think that a spot a spot etf
would have done it in one day if they
would have launched a bitcoin spot etf
we would have gone from zero to a
billion in less than one trading day and
every single person on wall street would
have perked up and said what the hell
was that it goes back to the idea
bitcoin is good for business now all of
a sudden we have people who are starting
to enter into the space and they're
saying wait a second this is really
different than any other market we've
ever seen it's global it's understood by
100 plus million people who already hold
the asset and it has the best marketing
team in the world on the internet we
literally memed a trillion dollar asset
into the hands of institutional
investors they have no choice but to buy
this asset now and that's part of the
beauty we have a second bitcoin linked
etf that is gonna launch the valkyrie
bitcoin futures etf is set to launch
tomorrow friday now one of the
disappointing parts of this is they
originally came out with their
application and they said it was going
to be listed as btf that was going to be
the ticker we all were excited and
laughing at the fact that valkyrie then
put an edit to their application and
said no it's going to be btfd by the
[ __ ] dip but they have now
backtracked my guesses that the sec did
not like the idea of them having the
ticker btfd and instead now it will list
as btf unfortunate
of course the fun police has to step in
and not allow them to use the btfd
ticker symbol but good try i think they
get points for simply trying to
incorporate internet culture as i
tweeted this morning those that
understand internet culture have a
distinct competitive advantage in this
market when you were dealing with retail
investors when they have very specific
types of jokes or uh memes and culture
and conversations and language and you
can start to actually appeal to that
stuff it tends to be a very smart
decision from a business perspective so
we now have the first etf it's in the
market it's got over a billion dollars
in assets we'll have the second one
start trading tomorrow my guess is that
this one will see inflows that will be
pretty impressive but i don't think
we'll see a replication the first one's
gonna kind of steal the show the second
one it would be hard to see them coming
in and actually getting any sort of you
know billion plus dollars uh worth of
assets in the first two days right yeah
i'm sure you know the first one sucks up
a lot of the capital that's looking for
a place to go i think so they they'll
obviously get more of the assets i think
it's whacked that they made them change
the name first off that's not cool
that's loser stuff right there uh but
the other thing i was thinking about
this yesterday was people on the
internet when bitcoin broke the all-time
high they a lot of them were commenting
about how people got in early and all
this kind of stuff right but i think the
one thing that people uh often forget
that aren't as familiar with the
industry or don't look at bitcoin um all
the time is that people that got in
early are continuing to buy right like
the the people that are in bitcoin the
most and have the largest uh amount of
assets and capital in the space
currently they continue to buy as the
prices rise right they look at more of a
savings account or a longer term play
knowing that it's a cap supply at 21
million so i think when you think of a
spot etf and other products like that
the the demand for this is only going to
continue to increase right as these
assets continue to go up in value the
demand from both retail and
institutional investors people are going
to go at this asset really hard and i
think if there's a spot etf sure it
might take a day but long term it's
going to be a massive massive product in
the market
so
on top of the etfs launching what i
think is interesting is now these
institutions that want to play in the
space we just talked about the houston's
fire uh the houston firefighters pension
fund actually has now bought bitcoin and
put it on the balance sheet they bought
bitcoin and ether about 25 million
dollars in total put it on their balance
sheet so that's pretty impressive i
believe that we are on the precipice of
more and more of these institutions
going direct and trying to get the
exposures previously what they did right
when we went uh well myself jason and
mark and we convinced the very first
pension fund in the united states to
invest in this asset class or in this
industry what they had to do is they
invested in a venture capital fund that
about 20 15 to 20 of it was gonna go
into bitcoin so you couldn't actually
get the direct exposure you had to go
through a manager that manager then had
to have a specific fund structure and
then we could get them the exposure now
it's worked out very well for them but
when you start to get the actu actual
institutions being able to directly
allocate and buy it themselves they're
either gonna do it by buying spot
bitcoin let's say for example and
putting it in custody somewhere or
they're going to be going into some of
these etfs the etf structure currently
is uh using this contango mechanism
which we're not going to get into
because it's a little complex but
basically what it does is it looks at
the fee structure of the fund is only
one of the things you have to be worried
about there's also a cost to being able
to carry the futures contracts and so
right now this structure is actually got
about 20 annualized uh fees from what i
saw and so when you start thinking about
a 20 annualized fee structure it's not
conducive to buying it and holding it
for long periods of time what's more
likely is that people are going to use
this because it's going to track the
price of bitcoin uh pretty uh accurately
so far and they're going to use it as a
trading mechanism and come in and out of
it they're not going to just say let me
buy this and hold it for two three five
years because if it's literally eating
away so much from a fee standpoint i'm
basically going to drastically trail the
asset that i'm trying to get exposure to
the btf etf i think should be watched
closely because the volume really does
matter but in the grand scheme of
bitcoin i don't think it really matters
i think it matters more for future um
future future etfs right um and those
trading because i believe another one is
going to start trading on monday of next
week as well so more and more of these
are getting ramped up look this is what
happens when you approve one and don't
approve a bunch at the same time let
them trade on the same day all the
capital initially flows into one we'll
see over time if it gets dispersed but i
saw to your point i saw a chart of oil's
price versus the oil futures etf when it
launched and it's lagged by like 90 in
some cases depending on kind of the time
period so yeah it's a great product for
institutional people and traders to
trade around and make money on and use
their technical analysis and charts and
stuff like that but if you're just a
regular person like us who just wants
exposure to the asset class and actually
own bitcoin physically then then you
should just buy the bitcoin yourself
going back though to the firefighters
thing i was just looking this up and i
thought it was super interesting was
like they literally just followed the
pitch that everyone's been saying and
you've been saying for years which is
just get a little bit of exposure right
they have uh four billion dollars in
assets the houston firefighters pension
fund so the way it works is there's 6
600 active and retired fire firefighters
in the fund and since 2004 they've
contributed nine percent of their annual
salary to the fund so the fund has four
billion in assets and they did 25
million in bitcoin and ether right so a
very very very small percentage of
exposure but then the uh the chief
investment officer of the fund
essentially just said it's a tool to
manage my risk it has positive expected
return and it manages my risk it has a
very low correlation to every other
asset class you ready for this yeah
december 24th 2018 you want me to just
pull up the receipts we're in receipt
season now
december 24 2018 i wrote publicly every
pension fund should buy bitcoin i
literally got laughed at bitcoin was at
about 3 200 bucks there it is there's
your receipt
every pension function
look at that [ __ ] literally receipts
literally every single person was
laughing you should do it you should do
the tweet with this thing
literally i'll i'll tweet that later
today every pension fund should buy
bitcoin and i literally
and i went through the whole thing if
you go down uh matt scroll down here a
little bit there's two bullet points
that you'll see and here was the
argument it's real simple bitcoin's a
non-correlated asset bitcoin has an
asymmetric return profile houston fires
uh finally what he just said yeah
uh the houston firefighters they bought
into bitcoin more than 10x later than
when i was telling them to go do this
stuff right every single pension fund in
the entire country is gonna buy bitcoin
why because it is non-correlated it's an
asymmetric return profile asset
literally three years later it's still
true this is the absolute best most
pristine asset you can put on your
balance sheet bitcoin is good for
business i said in 2018 it's 2021 i'm
still saying the same thing we literally
now or in in this case at this point
bitcoin was about 3 500 bucks maybe what
day was it 3 500 bucks
right now this is december 24th 2018
which means that we're up almost 20 x
from when i wrote this yeah it was uh
what was it 3700 basis 3700 so about
like 15 to 17x from when i wrote this
that's what i'm talking there's two
different ways to go about it though
there's the extreme example which is put
every single dollar you have in the
pension fund into bitcoin and then
there's the other side of the extremists
which is put zero dollars right i think
everyone should have a little bit of
exposure uh institutions pension funds
anything that you can get because if it
is um if it if it hockey sticks
basically it's gonna have exponential
growth and it will grow as an allocation
of your fault so let's just do the quick
math i'm not a public math guy you tell
me where i'm wrong but 25 million
investment 17x is 425 million their fund
is 4 billion so that's 12 and a half
percent essentially of their entire fund
correct yeah that was pretty good math
right there
that's wild though right like they
literally would have taken what was
essentially a meaningless bet 25 million
is a lot of money but in the grand
scheme the beauty of an asymmetric bet
is that you can invest very small
amounts and when you invest very small
amounts the asymmetry takes over again
every single public company in the
entire united states could have taken
over the last 12 to 18 months two
percent of their balance sheet literally
if you have 100 million dollars you take
two percent they put it in bitcoin
because it has gone up so much in terms
of five six hundred percent two percent
would have taken care of protecting the
entire balance sheet from the five and a
half percent cpi inflation that we're
experiencing right now literally that's
it you can take a very small amount you
can put it in and it will protect your
balance sheet and that's true of a
pension fund that's true of an endowment
a foundation a publicly traded company a
privately traded company or your
personal balance sheet and that is the
beauty of the asset i've been saying it
for years and as we continue going up
and more and more people capitulate i'll
just keep pulling up the receipts and
just run what is run the tape what is
going to convince these pension funds
and these institutions to say all right
enough is enough we need exposure to
this they're convinced now there's no
more needing to convince them they all
know they have to do this now and the
whole key was two things one you needed
the macro environment to get so bad and
then feel the pain so bad that they
called uncle they literally said okay
fine fine fine fine i don't know where
to put my money i'm in search of yield
i'm in search of protection from
inflation i'll go and i'll find
somewhere to put the assets right so it
was already bad enough and i've been
saying this for years and then
eventually it got so bad then another
okay okay okay the second thing is
somebody else had to do it first yeah
right there had to be somebody else it's
kind of like in the military when he
says like the first guy through the door
gets shot
right somebody else go first you got to
take the career risk because by the way
you get no credit for this going well
you only have yourself exposed to being
fired if you're an institutional
investor they don't get it's not like a
private asset manager right where you
say hey i get 20 carry
most of these public pension fund
investors they just get their salaries
and maybe they get a bonus here or there
but it's not tied directly to
performance so if all of a sudden you
went in and you bought even if it was 25
million dollars of bitcoin in this case
and it went to zero
you're you're definitely under the gun
if not fired yeah right and the
firefighters are saying what the hell
are you buying right but if it works out
then all of a sudden everyone's like oh
thanks appreciate it and they move on to
the next they don't even think about it
right they don't remember the risk that
was taking the courage the conviction
etc and that's why if you look at like
the uh fairfax uh police department and
the fairfax employees right those two
cios they were incredibly
forward-thinking they're the first two
public pensions in the entire united
states to do this uh and it proved to
work out for them right you buy bitcoin
at the price you deserve and if you wait
you pay an ignorance tax if you did not
buy it before you now have to pay a
higher price why because you weren't
paying attention or you were paying
attention you decided not to do it and
you could that's not a bad thing right
some people just say hey look as an
institutional investor i don't have the
air cover to do it i can't get it past
my investment committee uh i've got an
uh consultant and that consultant won't
let me do it right there's all these
different reasons why and most
institutional investors are not just
thinking about how high can something go
they're also thinking about how low can
it go how much money can i lose what is
the uh political risk that i'm taking
and also to some degree i don't want to
have to answer a bunch of questions to
local reporters that are asking me like
why did you take the firefighter's
pension fund and put in bitcoin yeah
right but now all of a sudden you could
say well because the government won't
stop printing all this damn money and
there's five plus percent inflation and
we think that it's only going to
continue to happen in terms of the
manipulation of interest rates and
quantitative easing and so it actually
may get worse and oh by the way all i'm
doing is i'm replicating the same
investment that paul tudor jones stanley
druckenmiller ray dalio steve cohen etc
are all doing you guys think they're
great investors so why are we not doing
it yeah the landscape has changed where
now they have the career risk removed
and they can get in the game i was just
gonna say that exact same thing which is
that uh it's much easier now because you
can point to all the data right you say
look the inflation's running super hot
it's over five percent uh the economy is
not really good right now but then also
just look at the historical returns of
bitcoin as an asset class right over the
10 years it's gone up tremendously in
value and appreciated so i don't know
how much cash they hold on their balance
sheet the houston firefighters fund
specifically but i just looked it up
quickly it says out of the top 100 uh
retirement funds in the u.s over 50 of
all assets are held in debt and 32 are
held in equities right so that's 82
roughly then the rise to split up
between a few other things in cash so
i'm assuming they hold somewhere between
maybe 5 10 in cash at any given point
well the cash is one piece but then also
how would you say their fixed income or
debt was fifty percent so fifty percent
they have two billion dollars the
houston firefighters pension fund has
literally two billion dollars two
billion dollars is incinerating right in
front of our eyes it's just melting away
it's like sand in your hand it's just
falling through the the uh fingers there
that's the average fun but yes okay yes
whatever the average pension fund two
billion dollars if you've got a four
billion dollar fund is absolutely
getting decimated they are destroying
the wealth of the pensioneers if they're
just sitting in debt now here's what i
will say is there is a very specific
type of risk management framework and
process that's in place for these
institutional investors so for example
let's say that we were all running one
of these institutions like a public
pension fund what we would do is we
would come together and say okay what is
the contribution that everyone's gonna
make and that's usually determined not
by the investment committee by uh
politicians and and others within the
organization so let's say that
everyone's gonna contribute one percent
of their salary into the pension right
that's their pension contribution and
the promise is that when they go to
retire that there's actually money there
for them to uh get it our job as the
investment committee would be to invest
well if we're going to actually be good
at our job what do we do we want to
cover our ass we don't want them to come
and sue us are we mad at us fire us
whatever so we come up with an
investment uh process an investment
mandate it's very simple we say okay we
are going to have a very specific
process we're going to evaluate we're
going to write reports we're going to uh
talk about it we're going to vote on it
we're going to then either approve or
deny and then we're going to go and get
the allocations we document all that
then we come out and we say here is
going to be our investment mandate right
or basically our portfolio construction
we're going to target to have 20
in uh fixed income we're going to 20 in
real estate we're gonna have 60
in uh equities right or whatever it ends
up being and we can change that over
time but there's a process to change the
mandate and so ultimately one these
assets don't fit into that mandate right
again why did we have to go and use a
venture capital style fund well if you
go and you say hey buy bitcoin they say
okay is it a currency is it a commodity
is it an equity what is this thing right
it doesn't fit into one of the buckets
yeah is it real estate right what bucket
doesn't fit in the bucket so it's hard
for them to allocate instead of you show
us hey we got a venture capital fund
okay that goes to my venture capital
allocation i can go ahead and i can do
that so that's one thing is they've got
to basically now start you're going to
see pension funds around the country uh
over the next let's call it 24 months
start saying okay let's add a crypto
bucket right or some sort of digital
asset bucket to our investment portfolio
or investment mandate that's step one
the second thing is they're gonna have
to do a ton of education with their
investment committees if you go around
the country and you look at the pension
investment committees the members
they're usually well-respected older
people in their communities there's not
a lot of young 30 you know uh 20 year
olds 30 year olds four-year-olds that
are on those committees usually much
older people people are lawyers doctors
bankers uh investment managers etc that
are part of these investment committees
they have a vote in what you do so you
have to do education in order to get
them excited about actually allocating
to this stuff and then on top of all of
that you then have to be able to do it
in a way that provides the ultimate kind
of career risk removal or cover for them
because you're gonna have to have
insurance you're gonna have to be able
to pass outsource due diligence like
there's all these components to it so
it's not just so much like hey let's go
convince all the chief investment
officers they should do this many of
them already know they should do it now
we're getting into the bureaucracy in
the process the process is there for a
reason it's there because it's supposed
to protect the pensioneers money right
but this is the downside is when you
have an asset that is moving quickly
we're talking about years now right i
mean there's many pension funds that i'm
not going to name that i went and i
talked to in 2018 and 2019 they still
not allocated and some of them were uh
somewhat flippant about it they were you
know just kind of hey laughed me out of
the room you know see ya but some of
them were like man we know we need to do
this but like we got a long road ahead
of us gotta change our investment
mandate we gotta go to the investment
committee we gotta get an approval
process
by the way i don't envy them i don't
want to be doing that stuff right like
that like that's a game i don't want to
play well you not only have to educate
yourself you have to educate other board
members or anyone else that's involved
in the approval process and then you
almost have to be so educated that if
anyone asks you a question reporters any
pen uh any other pensioners or anything
like that um you have to be able to
answer those questions with conviction
and certainty of what you're saying and
that i think is the biggest problem it
goes back to the education of the asset
well and it's not just pensions right i
think that's a lot of the reason why we
haven't seen more we've seen some
obviously with microstrategy and tesla
and some of these other companies add
bitcoin to their balance sheet as a
corporation but i think that's a big
reason why we haven't seen more right
they have to answer to their
shareholders usually they have a board
that they have to go to and get this
approved by or at least talk to them
about if they don't have control over it
so i think these are all things that
over time they'll play out as we get
older in the asset class and there's
more historical returns and evidence and
more people like you mentioned before
are getting in the asset class and
owning it and etc but i just think that
uh this doesn't only imply to pensions
and when we start to see all these
people move in it's gonna it's gonna
drastically uh bring in more demand and
we know what the supply side looks like
so uh price is uh i wanna speaking of
price i wanna pull up this chart yaseen
from arc invest uh posted this and i
thought this was just an excellent um
kind of uh visual in terms of what we've
seen in the past what this chart shows
is the bitcoin returns after fully
recovering from a 50 drawdown now there
have been five times in the history of
bitcoin that there's been at least a 50
drawdown and then we came back and we
actually recovered from it and so what
we see in this chart here is if we go
all the way to the far left there the
very first drawdown was 94
that 94 drawdown we then had to come
back and actually recover so we kind of
got back to what that previous all-time
high was from there we got a 708
increase in price
followed by a 75 decrease in price or a
drawdown came back we recovered from
that recovery then we went up 343
so 700 then about 350 percent after that
we went down 86
that 86 drawdown we recovered from there
once we recovered that third time we
went up one thousand six hundred and
twenty percent literally sixteen hundred
percent increase uh next eighty-five
percent drawdown after that eighty-five
percent drawdown we went up 228 percent
at 228 percent was all the way up to
that 64 000 price point following that
64 000 uh dollar peak earlier this year
we then went down 56 percent so this
drawdown specifically is a little bit
lighter than it has been in some of
those other major drawdowns but that 56
000 56
drawdown we have now recovered from once
we come back and we recover the question
is how high will we go and how high we
will go is unknown but we can look at
those historicals and so what yasin
included in the tweet was he said that
bitcoin has fully recovered from a 50
drawdown for the only the fifth time in
history if bitcoin returns half of what
it returned the last time bitcoin would
hit 125 000
but if it returns half of what the
average return is bitcoin will then hit
300 000
so what he's basically looking at is
that let's focus on the last one if you
take the average amount of the upside
post a 50 recovery what you then do is
you cut that in half so you take the
average divide it by two and that would
put bitcoin still at a 300 000 price
point and so what he's saying here is
nobody knows what's going to happen in
the future but this historical analysis
shows that every time bitcoin has
suffered a 50
or more drawdown and it comes back which
it has every time there is usually
fireworks in terms of how high it goes
moving forward i don't read charts at
candlesticks or anything i don't get
into the uh the nitty-gritty but that
chart looks great
it looks great uh and going into the
next the rest of this year and then into
next year i think um
i think we're only gonna all this stuff
is helpful
my only uh thing with that chart right
is like
all those drawdowns are much greater
than 50 correct so they're all 75 or
more so and then i think the other main
difference is typically these are
drawdowns after the bull market right so
when we go into that bear market phase
before the next halving typically we
this uh bull market run has been a
little different because of everything
that happened right when china went
offline and we saw this other stuff so
it'll be interesting to see how it
recovers bitcoin's super resilient it's
obviously proven that for a long period
of time so i'm not saying it won't uh
but those are just the things that i
would think of when i start looking at
this we hit 1.5 k likes which means that
we're giving out another 150 worth of
free bitcoin what i want you to do right
now in the chat is i want you to go
ahead and drop
one what is your absolute favorite uh
chart or data point around bitcoin and
your twitter account twitter account and
what is your favorite data point or
chart when analyzing bitcoin and what
we're going to do is we're going to pick
one person right now they're going to
get 150 worth of bitcoin for free you
keep smashing the like button on the
video we'll keep giving out free bitcoin
what john curious how many people are
going to say stock to flow
is that that is that the easy one yeah i
also got told that there's some time
like a 30 second delay from the time
that uh i'm talking to what you see so
we we're told that we should wait a
little bit longer joe was all over the
list
joe is telling me that we should wait a
little bit longer before we actually
pick who the winner is so that's what
we're going to do
[Laughter]
we're giving out 150 worth of free
bitcoin right now go ahead leave in the
chat what is your twitter account and
what is your favorite data point or
chart john who are you going to pick
jonathan rebelo why are you picking that
person
just cause i saw his name he said stock
to flow model not even close
all right congrats
jonathan rebello congratulations you win
150 in bitcoin congratulations we
appreciate you coming here every single
day to watch by the way if i was sitting
at home right now and i was watching i
would definitely hit the like button
because it's at 1.9 k and if we cross
over two that means there's another 150
bucks coming to everybody uh we have
bill here with us from abra how are you
i'm good man how are you
i'm excited yes
what a week what a month what is summer
fall
let's start with this i was telling my
brothers uh very interesting background
that i don't think a lot of people don't
know explain what you did before abra
well i'm old
in crypto years uh so i've been around
the space for about 30 years by the
space i mean crypto when it was
cryptography
i was at netscape after the cia and i
stand at goldman where i worked in fixed
income which we'll talk about this
morning and uh yeah for the last uh 15
years i've basically been working on
mobile banking uh obviously bitcoin
crypto and now abra for the last six
years okay and then abra is what how do
you describe it i describe as a crypto
banking service right we let you buy
sell trade about 100 different
cryptocurrencies we have a high yield
service that lets you earn anywhere from
four to eight percent on crypto we just
announced a a new uh rewards token which
i'll talk about more
we've run a lending service for both
retail uh which is booming now and i
think that's going to be the future of
what i call crypto banking and also an
institutional lending service which is
all part of how we generate the yield
that consumers make on the crypto
holdings all right i want to talk about
the macro environment because it's
absolutely bonkers what's happening
right now uh we've got
five percent plus uh cpi inflation we
got four percent core inflation we have
about four and a half to five percent of
unemployment we have 11 million open
jobs that's what they admit to
we don't have five percent
cpi okay let's explain a bunch of
[ __ ] okay i mean i've been saying
this for
i mean how long have you and i've talked
about this i've been saying this for a
couple of years now even before kovitt
the inflation numbers were a bunch of
nonsense and now it's
i'm guessing based upon all the data
that i see both anecdotal and literal
charts and everything else when you look
at specifics the only thing that's
dragging it down is is productivity and
tech okay right explain what you think
it is i think in in real world terms
inflation is well over ten percent right
now okay uh i i'll get into like just
anecdotes on housing
myself having been outbid by like six
homes
in the last six months and finally just
overpaid like an insane amount of money
just to get a house okay
i the reason that i think that it's not
even higher
is because there's a counterbalance on
on tech growth which is exponential and
has a you know a counterbalance in terms
of the increases in productivity you get
but it's not enough right now to deal
with the staples that are going up in
price the home prices that are going up
just just the lack of workers you can
see people are not willing to work for
twelve dollars an hour anymore correct
it's exactly mcdonald's is now paying 21
an hour i saw they're paying 21 an hour
just to get somebody to come and
literally be the cashier uh wash dishes
run the fry machine or try to fix the
ice cream machine try try getting a home
remodel done today try getting the
basics the wood the you know the
materials the workers i mean and compare
it to what it would have cost two three
years ago i mean people are anecdotally
saying we're literally talking 50 60
more for the same remodel as two to
three years ago right just because you
know
get in line first of all right the
workers are unavailable and the
materials are either unavailable or the
prices have gone through the roof food
i'm i go shopping it's unreal right so i
don't know how they do this calculation
if they just literally pull it out of
their ass or decide arbitrarily what to
take off the list but like i said the
only reason that i think it's not being
reported as 10 plus percent is the
counterbalance in tech
but i i don't think that they're being
uh intellectually honest at all with the
numbers that you're seeing so you're on
the best business show the best business
show you might not know this has the
best research team okay one day we went
and we broke down the cpi rent index and
how they calculate it yeah it
literally on a monthly basis they survey
it comes out to like 10 000 homes and
they're in predetermined areas that are
determined by what was the 1990 census
or something is where they've decided to
count from and the current cpi rent
index when we did the analysis like a
month ago is under two percent increase
but zillow is almost 10 and
apartments.com was 14
all right and then you say well how does
zillow calculate there's like oh we have
a hundred million data points
and i would say one thing too is when
you talk to like individual business
business owners the responses are
completely different right so i was
talking to a buddy of mine uh who john
knows also and he runs a meat district
packaging and distribution company so if
you go to the grocery store and you see
basically meat that looks like they made
it in the back that's what they do and
they deliver it to the stores he said
not only can they not they're looking to
hire like 50 workers can't find anyone
to do it right for the amount that they
were paying before and then he says that
when they aggregate everything together
their inflation percentage for their
business and the goods that they're
buying is 20 percent so just completely
different than five uh the
shout out real quick uh there's somebody
here who owns two restaurants tackology
and cantina which he's gonna be excited
that we're talking about it and we we
were recently eating there in great
restaurants yeah he came to uh say hi to
us and while we're talking to him i just
asked him i said hey what's going on and
he was like can't find any workers right
there anyone who wants to come he's like
i offered them you know ten dollars to
uh wash dishes he's like we'll do it for
16. right he's just like this is nuts
yeah and then he steak
up a hundred percent wow
right he's like by the way like
literally he's like
i forget how long he said he had been
doing it i think it was a you know 10 20
years or something like that and he said
it was the first time in his career that
he's had to hire an outside agency to
find workers for his business yes which
is crazy think about the problem that
the government has created for
themselves i started using the word
stagflation
months ago when everybody said the
economy was about to boom i actually
think the economy is about to
to retract and the problem is is that
with rising prices for this reason they
can't raise rates
right so they've put themselves into a
corner right now where fixed income is
just is already worthless and and i
don't know if there's degrees of
worthless but if it could become more
worthless it's about to become more
worthless and i just tweeted this out
based on what you were saying earlier
it's not a bitcoin right now to me
the narrative is wrong it's not about
replacing gold it's about replacing the
hundred trillion dollars of fixed income
in portfolios that is completely
worthless right and explain this to
people because people don't understand
if they're not in the investment world
they don't understand what that 100
trillion dollars of fixed income is like
who has that money and what are they
trying to accomplish by allocating it to
fix it the mass the biggest part of it
is obviously u.s debt but but the 130
plus trillion represents a global debt
footprint whether it's corporate debt
individual debt mortgages rolled into
bonds uh you know federal debt for
multiple countries european debt uh but
in the aggregate it's over 100 trillion
dollars and that debt is effectively in
my opinion worthless okay uh and at some
point
we're all just gonna mentally write it
off i don't know what that actually
translates into in terms of depression
war it worries me because dalio has
talked about this in terms of being in
these late stage debt cycles and
traditionally those have ended in war
which is obviously not what we want but
what we have now that we didn't have
last time is bitcoin right and this
massive movement towards
decentralization which i think could be
this planet saving grace versus this
worthless debt that we're all burdened
with right now in our portfolios so we
now have a couple of data points on this
right so we have the houston
firefighters are coming out today saying
they put 25 million dollars into bitcoin
and ether uh which on average we were
just talking about the average public
pension funds about 50 into fixed income
type assets pimco one of the world's
most famous largest 2.2 trillion dollar
asset manager that specializes in fixed
income now saying that they're going to
start getting into uh cryptocurrencies
in general i think right now they own
equities that give them exposure but now
they're actually going to start uh
buying and trading in the actual assets
themselves
is this just like the crack in the wall
and when you get one or two public
pensions putting it directly on their
balance sheet you get a pim code they
start playing and then all of a sudden
here comes this massive tsunami of yeah
the damn analogy with this couple of
small cracks is probably the best one
and and the cracks are basically like
scratches the the dam is made of iron
we've just started scratching it with
the nail and and it when it opens and
and the floodgates are are it's it's you
can't there's no going back right the
dam is broke forever and i think
you know late last year people thought
that institutional money was coming into
bitcoin
i would posit that wasn't really true to
the extent people believed i actually
believe it was mostly high net worth
money family offices and a lot of
futures and and basically playing the
arb trades that was driving the price
which is fine
now because so much money has come off
of exchanges we are getting
institutional interest because with a
two trillion dollar asset class a lot of
these institutions can look at bitcoin
and they couldn't before because it was
simply too small i mean if blackrock
wanted to basically put ten percent of
assets in bitcoin then it's it's not
possible even today it's not possible
it's the only asset in the world that as
it gets bigger it actually becomes more
attractive exactly because they're not
they're not interested i mean they're
not interested in a 300
per year return they're interested in
principal preservation and a reasonable
you know alpha versus the market that
they can show that they're adding value
somehow to justify ridiculous salaries
and other comp you know what that they
have right that's it and that's fine
right but bitcoin now represents right a
way to get around the 40
of these portfolios that is going to
effectively show no return there's going
to be a blip because they're going to
try to basically do quantitative easing
76 000 and squeeze a little bit more out
of out of the bond markets and the
government will keep buying as it has
been but but effectively it's it's more
lipstick on a dead pig yeah right so
when they start to come into the market
how do you think that they're going to
actually play this is we see you know
pimco is just one of many fixed income
asset managers okay let's buy some
equities that give us indirect exposure
they've been able to do that now we've
got this bitcoin futures etf eventually
i'm assuming we'll get a bitcoin spot
etf i can go buy the assets themselves i
could allocate to a manager and they can
go do it like how do you think about
their entry point into the market and
then what is the um impact or the pros
and cons of each one of those yeah it's
a great question well first of all i'm
very disappointed i mean look as
somebody who is irresponsibly long
bitcoin and has most of his net worth in
bitcoin and abra stock anything that
promotes bitcoin i'm happy about
but you know the government is the
federal government i won't pick on the
states because some of them are getting
it right the federal government is
batting a thousand when it comes to this
stuff they get it wrong every [ __ ]
time
and and to create a
futures-based etf as the first product
i'm sorry it's just so dumb because the
average retail investor has no idea what
they're buying
if you explain to them like okay do you
know what contango means in terms of
what's happening their heads will spin
and these are the dance moves right the
dance move exactly and they just put up
over a billion dollars in this in 36
hours it makes no sense right but that's
the overlords telling us that they're
going to protect us from ourselves right
as opposed to actually creating a spot
product where you can actually audit the
custody and and send in the irs to do
their bsa audits and whatever it is that
that they do to protect retail investors
and and create a damn spot and i
actually don't think we're going to get
a spot etf anytime soon because i think
they still believe they're going to
protect us from ourselves which makes no
sense okay so put that aside
institutions that want to invest in
bitcoin don't need
the securities markets to do it today
correct and and they're probably not
going to because of the inefficiencies
and the fees associated with it right no
large institution is going to pay two
percent
to to grayscale for for custodying
bitcoin most of the inflows to grayscale
i think uh and this is a testament to
the the product that they built was
because there was no redemptions there
was the premium and so people were
arbiting the premium and then once that
flipped that's where then all of a
sudden people said wait a second this
might not be the best way to get
exposure yeah and that was a big part of
the run-up last year just you know
intellectual honesty right i mean that
was definitely part of what was going on
uh but thank you barry yeah for sure you
know full disclosure he's one of my
first investors love barry great guy
great product very smart um but it's not
a good institutional product right i
mean there are very simple ways through
prime brokers now to get exposure if you
look at what you know sailor did
microstrategy i mean they don't disclose
it until afterwards because they don't
want to drive the price up because they
want to buy at the lowest price possible
but they're just spreading the orders
around prime brokers which is exactly
what tesla would do and all of these
institutions are literally they actually
publish not not lit like
not a figurative playbook they literally
publish the playbook on how to do it so
now these institutions know exactly
which prime brokers to go to they can
also work with companies like abra and
and block find others to actually borrow
against those holdings now which is
that's i think that's becoming the
mantra of how you replace fixed income
with bitcoin hold the appreciating asset
borrow the the [ __ ] coin depreciating
asset and run your business that way
that's the future of fixed income now
that's a 10 15 year transition that's
just starting this year yep right the
idea of what we're talking about would
have been impossible years ago the asset
wasn't worth enough to have any
meaningful borrow how do you think about
these people coming into the market with
trillions of dollars and bitcoin today
sitting at it you know near an all-time
high is this something where it has a
short-term impact or is the long-term
play well i still think we get those
kind of the volatility via futures
markets that the retail investors mostly
don't understand meaning
if there's so little bitcoin on
exchanges that everybody talks about
supply shocks will comes on talks about
supply shocks why the hell does the
price go down 20 on occasion right why
does it just keep going up in a straight
line well you have this tension between
you know overbought futures and and
liquidations that happen and the fact
that you know spot basically has a
supply shock a permanent supply shock
now right i think what's going to happen
is as the price and the market cap goes
up
futures ability to have a short-term
big impact on on pullbacks is going to
get diminished and then you're going to
basically see
you know the price just go up up up up
to a point where even stock to flow
and other kind of on-chain economic
models don't really do much anymore and
and that's when the flood gates are
really open because it becomes a a
negative feedback loop where
institutions are now going to be
motivated to buy because you can have a
four trillion dollar asset a five
trillion dollar asset and all those
other metrics are going to go out the
window futures won't matter anymore um
you know then it'll be about
macroeconomic black swan events you know
are we going is the united states going
to war with china that will drive pull
down pullbacks at that point when it
really does start to replace fixed
income and i think we're several years
away from that happening how high can
bitcoin's price go well if it becomes
the collateral
for the future of fixed income
i mean in today's dollars that's 100
trillion but at that point i don't know
if the measurement in dollars matters
anymore we would measure bitcoin in
bitcoin right meaning this item costs
this many stats right at that point who
cares what a dollar is worth now
business may still use the dollar like i
think michael sarah and i we've talked
about this you know a few times i think
we disagree a little on this he thinks
the dollar is going to be around forever
i i'm not so sure
right um but you know at some point
you certainly can see it becoming the
collateral for all of these op debt
obligations which puts it in today's
terms at well over a hundred trillion
dollars so that would put bitcoin uh no
public math but about five million
dollars or more a per bitcoin yeah you
get to the point where it's like on par
sats are on par with pennies and dollars
right yeah which is an order a couple
orders of magnitude from where we are
now
so basically you're talking about if
bitcoin becomes the collateral for the
fixed income market everyone takes their
fixed income and says hey this is all
trash i'm gonna go and i'm gonna move to
this new asset when they do that if we
get to 100 trillion or so that comes
into the market where four and a half
five million dollar bitcoin price do you
think that's like a next five year thing
or that's like a 15. that's a 15-year
thing
um it'll certainly replace
gold in market cap long before then but
that's not the big play that's that's
not the measuring or yardstick that
matters to me personally right because
to me it's about the future of the
internet having money for the internet
first and foremost and we're there now
right lightning is working um you know
and if you look at other crypto models
stable coins are working
um layer twos are working across the
board
we'll see if they scale quickly or if it
takes a few years but the software
engineers will figure it out and then
ultimately it's about dealing with this
this late stage debt cycle and how we
you know china is is worrying me right
now right and so how do we well i mean
you look at the moves that they're
making in terms of you know just pulling
in capitalism uh you know looking at how
to manage resources because i think that
that the planners the people who plan
ahead there believe that we're about to
have a massive resource supply shock on
this planet and they're preparing for a
fight i really believe that they think
that the worst case scenario is a fight
over global resources and if you look at
the investments they're making in africa
and other places we're asleep at the
wheel totally asleep at the wheel the
u.s europe nobody gets it right
everybody's fat and happy right now and
not paying attention to the big picture
and i hope that this global movement
towards decentralization that we're in
the middle of saves us but it's not
guaranteed
right when you think about uh those
investments do we think that china's ban
on mining is uh pushing let's call
everyday citizens and kind of retail
investors in china pushing them out of a
market where there's freedom technology
there's censorship resistance there's
kind of an immutable public ledger etc
but actually the politicians are just
sitting there and they hold a bunch of
bitcoin as well i think they look at
bitcoin like a company in in that regard
and and they've banned twitter they've
googled as a matter of fact it's the
best proxy probably over the last 20
years as to where to make your bets
right just look at what china bans make
an investment in it you will have the
best returns
there should be a fund it's called the
china ban me fund
and you should put all of your money in
that fund it's probably close to arc
minus tesla right and it's just a price
go up fund because you know there's a
reason they can't control it if you're
in a totalitarian society and you can't
control something well you have a
problem because
what you're all about is control yeah so
it's it's obvious what the problem is
right and and so bitcoin represents the
opposite of what a totalitarian system
stands for and and that includes by the
way the overreach in control in a
democratic society right because we had
a pendulum swing
one way post world war ii up until 71 72
right when we came off the gold standard
which was peak centralization
right and the pendulum is now slowly
swinging the other way
and the overlords don't know how to deal
with it yeah the movement towards
decentralization is orthogonal to how a
federal regulator thinks about anything
because their goal ultimately is to is
perceive to protect the consumer from
themselves do you think they actually
believe that they're protecting people
or do you think they're 100 they do i
don't think these are look i i have
people i talk to people at all these
regulators all the time they're not evil
people yeah i agree with that yeah and
and i think that they do
genuinely believe that they're there to
do good and that people need to be
protected like i have friends that i
disagree with that the cfpb consumer
financial protection bureau it's a bunch
of nonsense to me that doesn't mean that
they're dumb people i i have friends
there that you know law degrees from
harvard math degrees from harvard you
know these are not stupid people they
they just see the world differently
than i do right and i think the way most
bitcoiners do if you were the president
of the united states what would you do
how would you just go and buy a bunch of
bitcoin and put on the balance sheet
what would you i would certainly be
putting a bunch of assets on the balance
sheet in bitcoin and i would try to
figure out how to replace the fed with
something that actually works long term
given where we are in this debt cycle i
would be very focused on that and it
would probably make me very unpopular uh
with both parties because ultimately
when it comes to money there's very
little difference between the two
parties right it's it's more about
social issues and other things in
centralization versus decentralization
that is is the big difference but that's
that's what i would do first and
foremost then i would look at tech
policies that embrace exponentially
growing tech and and re-establish the
us's footprint as the global leader in
anything that represents exponential
change whether it's robotics uh crypto
bitcoin and banking uh you know ar vr
healthcare you know genomics all of it i
would make the us
the the the tax
the best tax deal hub for anything
related to exponential tech and the
problem is is you have all these old
people that don't get it yeah right and
i don't know how you solve that problem
some of them still use flip phones i've
seen them joe john what questions you
guys got
i don't know about the flip phones uh
but so it goes back to your your
estimate for 100 trillion right how do
we have to get there and what kind of
stages do you see over what period of
time yeah so so i think that and and
what's really cool about this is you can
go back to the 1970s and austrian
economists wrote a playbook
for private money that this is playing
out to the letter and people don't
actually realize it's out there and they
there was no internet
obviously therefore no crypto
no mobile smartphones and yet these
people had the insight to say what would
happen if we had private money that was
guaranteed deflationary with no
opportunity for a print button right
they said well first it would be hoarded
it would be hoarded because you know
everybody would say hey this is the the
most valuable money we've ever had and
that's exactly what's been happening
right now because it trades 24 7 and the
futures markets we talked about before
it on the way up you know the price we
pay for being on the front lines of that
is the volatility but effectively what
they said would happen has been
happening so far which is step one it
will be hoarded eventually it will be
worth so much
right that the purse strings will have
to be loosened a little and it will make
no sense just to hoard it forever right
i don't know what point that is but that
point is coming
john what do you got
i'm curious about what are your
i guess hesitations around bitcoin right
so you're obviously very bullish is
there anything that scares you about the
asset
um about the asset no about you know
bitcoin is software use it or don't use
it um
i don't look i was on the other side of
the the debate in the in the block size
wars
um i lost
in terms of like what i would have done
right if i was an open source developer
i don't code anymore but um
lightning is working so far
we needed to scale like infinitely
higher than it is now in order to get to
like that next part of what i talked
about in the austrian playbook which is
we can at global scale
loosen up the first strings if a billion
people
wanted to spend bitcoin today it
wouldn't work right even with lightning
um and and and that's not a bad thing
it's just where we are in its
development
and i you know i'm all about software my
whole career has been about software but
but that's the next step we need that
software to scale
and so it's not a worry so much as just
hey just as a matter of fact where we
are and this is what needs to happen and
i also think we're heading towards a
multi-chain world which is the other
offshoot of or outshoot of output of the
2017 wars which is that you know there's
different types of crypto
uh platforms that can solve different
problems and a lot of my friends that
are all in on bitcoin and i'm all in a
bitcoin don't like that narrative um but
again it's just software use it or don't
use it and i do think that ethereum for
example is is solving really big
problems in the banking system and you
know a lot of my maxi friends don't like
that but it is true
when you think about uh
the institutions that are coming in
right now they're gonna go they're gonna
buy bitcoin they're gonna put on the
balance sheet what happens to the rest
of their portfolio how are they affected
by this are they going to have to move
from
kind of traditional stocks to something
else does equity get uh hurt venture
capital i'm assuming it's going to
continue to do well for for the uh
foreseeable future are there other parts
of the portfolio that get affected by
all this yeah so one interesting
question here is what do the top
companies in the fortune 100 actually do
with their own balance sheet how does
that affect the stock market right i was
tweeting yesterday about the fact that
apple microsoft google facebook still
owns zero bitcoin and are holding tens
of billions of dollars in what
effectively is trash
right why are they doing this right i
think what the reason that they're not
buying bitcoin is is because the
accountants and the tax lawyers are
telling them well watch what happens
when you get these pullbacks you have to
basically report that it's a negative
impact to the balance sheet but you
don't get to report the benefit when it
goes up that's just a nonsense gap
accounting issue which is going to be
fixed right so i think that these
companies are going to have no choice
but to start buying bitcoin and then
bitcoin becomes intertwined with the
stock market
right which microstrategy showed us you
know what can happen for one company
when it gets intertwined so i think what
happens is is that we start to see more
and more companies put bitcoin and
ethereum by the way institutions are
going to a lot of institutions are
skipping bitcoin and going to theorem we
can debate whether that's good or bad
but some are okay especially funds uh
but i think more large companies that
have a treasury perspective on this will
be buying bitcoin instead of ethereum i
think hedge funds may look for outsized
gains uh on on ethereum versus bitcoin
but i think you're going to see a market
where public equities become intertwined
with the crypto narrative because so
many of them are going to be holding
huge sums of bitcoin on their balance
sheet going forward
are we at a point now i was talking
yesterday about uh public company ceos
who do not
address the cash and cash equivalents
being 100 their balance sheet are they
violating the fiduciary duty i think so
i mean that's what i wrote yesterday i
look this is not just a bill pumping
bitcoin thing
put bitcoin aside for a second if you
have if you're holding an asset
right if your business is growing 10 a
year which is you know what you look for
in a in a growth public company and you
have an asset which is losing 10 of its
value a year that you're holding your
profits in well you have a problem
because you're basically doing a fred
flintstone in your car spinning your
wheels going nowhere right so what is
your responsibility at that point well
it's probably either to grow the value
of your treasury invest it in something
that has higher growth than you know
what you're doing with it which is
nothing or give it back to your
shareholders and of course they don't
want to give it back to the shareholders
they want to buy more shares ultimately
to make themselves richer that's part of
the problem right is is they they just
go back to the easy solution which is uh
we'll just buy back the shares make
ourselves richer and when the stock
price goes up everybody looks good short
term
we're in this interesting mode where one
of these rare scenarios where for the
next few months everything you own is
going to go up
including bonds by the way right so even
though it's trash i think bond market is
going to go up for for probably a few
weeks maybe even a few months and and
then it's going to revert back to the
mean which is [ __ ]
and and
at that point you know i don't know if
if if it's going to happen in 22
that the fixed income markets really
start to think about okay you know we
need to basically enable rias and others
to own to own uh bitcoin and to replace
the 40 percent or if people and
companies just do it on their own we'll
see yeah it's
fascinating when you start to think
about um
you're basically going to get not just
drop gold buy bitcoin you're going to
get dropped bonds by bitcoin 100 you're
going to get dropped like all the trash
assets that are sitting there that's it
and part of it we're just talking about
like these public pension funds that are
essentially locked into these investment
mandates or these asset allocations
they got a lot of work to do because
they're gonna go change the investment
mandate they've got to educate their uh
you know their board and there's a lot
of people who hey don't rock the boat
here right like like let's not get fired
let's not kind of screw up a good thing
this has been great to us but they're
looking at the past historical analysis
they're not necessarily looking at the
current environment yeah and they're
also not even like close to this
discussion yet yeah there's a lot of
people in that world and i used to work
in fixed income that don't even follow
what we're talking about yet all that
means is is from a contrarian investor
perspective there's nobody on the bus
and when you have conviction for an
investment and there's nobody else on
the bus that's when you should be the
most excited yeah so we we who are in
the middle of this think that it's like
late in the game it is not when you look
i mean the game is just starting from
from a macro perspective right yeah and
and that's why i think folks like you
know ralph paul are so excited because
they understand the rest of these global
markets that have no effing clue about
what's going on in our world they're
just starting to see that hey this
thing's worth two trillion dollars
what's going on yep right that's the
beginning of the game all right before
we bring kevin o'leary on tell us real
quick about abra kind of what uh you
guys are doing right now i know you guys
have made a bunch of progress raise more
money and assets seem to be going up
yeah we just closed our series c 40
million um we are managing well over a
billion now uh in re it's all retail
which is really hard we have a
developing markets business which is
killing it we actually really unique in
that we service very high net worth
clients in the us and in europe we also
have a developing markets business in
asia and central america all exactly the
same product you know buying and trading
crypto bitcoin ethereum bunch of other
cryptos uh the ability to earn yield we
just launched cardano yesterday so you
can earn interest on bitcoin ethereum
cardano eight percent on dollars we also
launched uh announced the new token
program
um we partnered with a new group out of
switzerland called the crypto banking
alliance it's going to be kind of a
quasi-education lobbying organization to
help promote uh d5 bitcoin ethereum
within the banking system and they have
a rewards token they've launched and and
they're giving 30 of that to our
customers as a reward for you know using
abra and then other companies will be
able to apply to grants from from that
alliance we have no ownership in it i
have no oversight of it it'll basically
do grants to whoever qualifies
and yeah we've got a bunch of other
products after that coming out so our
lending product which we announced in
march is now live in like 44 45 states
in the us and 50 countries that's been
our fastest growing product the last few
months um and we're pr every product we
have has been profitable for the company
and we've been profitable for about a
year now and probably 10x the revenue
over the last year or so
when you see that how is the
institutional market from not just hey
buying the assets i'm assuming that
we've seen a massive explosion venture
capital type investment even like the
late stage growth investors they're all
now turning and saying whoa hold on a
second here we know that there's going
to be continued demand increase the
market cap's going to continue to grow
that means the infrastructure businesses
are going to continue to grow and so
they're plowing capital in as well yeah
we're making a transition from it's kind
of like what happened with the internet
right in the early days people probably
never heard of verisign and some of
these early like infrastructure
companies that got the the big bets
early and then later on came google and
then facebook and then the kind of the
apps built on top of the internet that
hasn't happened yet at scale we're still
now seeing late stage money come into
you just saw ftx i think raised like 450
million
um and to me that's infrastructure right
the ability to to have those derivative
products and trade the next generation
is like what i'm talking about for abra
and the block fight and the others that
are basically building banking services
on top of that layer right that's i
think going to be a much bigger business
even than the exchanges themselves and
we haven't even started to see real late
stage money come into that market yet
right it's just now starting to hit the
exchanges three years ago there was no
late stage funding available yeah in
crypto true none right and so how fast
things change right
and and so now it's going to start to go
to applications of the crypto with
crypto banking i think being the big
first beneficiary of that how do you
guys think about your balance sheet in
terms of uh bitcoin cryptocurrencies and
cash do you have like a treasury policy
or we do we do so the only crypto that
we hold in masses is bitcoin on our own
balance sheet uh and it's a lot uh and
then you know the rest is in cash and
and honestly i'm trying to you know get
everybody comfortable with us holding
more and more and more in bitcoin and
putting our money where our mouths are
but we generate our profits actually in
bitcoin because of the way our trading
and yield system works and most of it we
just never sell yeah uh and so that just
keeps growing
and then the question right now is we
just closed our financing so we're
actually going through the the
permutations of you know how much of
that do we move back to bitcoin versus
how much spend
sorry how much of it do you want to move
into bitcoin uh i'd i'd move probably 80
percent
uh you know our there's a velocity of
money in our in our company in terms of
how we deal with ad spend and other
things which have to be done in cash but
i'd be comfortable with like 80 percent
yeah and on the balance sheet itself is
that about how much of the balance sheet
currently is in bitcoin no no no no okay
because up until now it's only been
revenue got it right and so um you know
we were a small company up until 18
months ago yeah and all of a sudden we
were profitable generating cash which is
staying in bitcoin and just raised all
this money and so now it's the new money
that we're we're trying to decide
treasury policy for it's fascinating
because michael saylor talks you know a
bunch about like hey we have our
business and we're going to try to grow
our business and drive more kind of
financial performance and do what
shareholders think of like
the business but then we have to have a
treasury policy as well and in some
weird way like your experience uh having
been an investor and working kind of in
more like an asset allocation uh uh kind
of world you start to think about like
okay well what are my liquidity needs
what is the risk i'm willing to take
what's the upside look like what does my
opportunity cost
like that treasury policy is starting to
look a lot different than just hey let's
buy cash cash equivalents and we'll be
fine yeah it's great that we have
companies in the crypto space that are
dealing with this issue now because it's
also going to show the non-crypto
companies how to deal with it yeah it's
fascinating you guys have any other
questions no thanks for coming bill my
pleasure appreciate it he's going to
stick around for uh for kevin o'leary
thing i i don't get it
kevin kevin o'leary is uh is late which
uh he's late we'll get my heart yeah i
mean he is late he is seven minutes late
yesterday was my fault we thought that
anthony's scary much he was late i told
him the wrong time so that was on me
this one's on kevin though he he is
definitely late today uh wait what is
the energy thing so so
if i understand correctly his his
argument is is that a lot of companies
won't invest in bitcoin right now
because of this you know fear of
basically being you know uh you know
anti-esg whatever and and the the
numbers just don't play it out it's it's
it's a false narrative we're going to
talk about it because i think that i
think it's changing now where they're
starting to realize this because at
first there's only a lot of energy
consumption like what is it and so now
all of a sudden what do we have to do we
had to go get all the work all the data
do the research create the reports put
it in their hands say no seriously the
data is right and now people are
starting to say okay like maybe this is
something not to mention the fact that
that would eliminate most of the fortune
100 from most balance sheets
yeah you know i mean it's just it's a
hypocritical narrative that that is
beyond being untrue
it just doesn't the math doesn't work
with the rest of you know well
christmas you know that right
the christmas lights are more than some
countries so you have to cancel
christmas
that's when they'll come for you all the
time oh timeout talk about this energy
thing yeah yeah exactly don't mess with
that uh we have them yet no not yet
kevin i know you can hear me let's go
where are you man uh the the other piece
of this i think uh around the energy
conversation is uh
in some crazy way everyone was real
worked up about it when it wasn't inside
the united states but i always go back
to like once the united states knows how
to make money from it then oh well you
know this might not be that bad and we
start to think about it differently
because there's tax revenue there's job
creation there's economic prosperity and
so i do think that like you literally
could have all of this uh energy
consumption happening somewhere else and
people would have really anti you know
uh narrative but then you bring it to
the united states and they still may
have somewhat of a negative view on it
but it's just a little bit less negative
because at least it's happening but this
is the beauty of free markets i listened
to your your awesome interview with nick
who after he gave his talk in texas
which was also amazing if you haven't
seen his deck everybody's got to go take
a look at it what other space has had to
go so deep in understanding energy and
energy consumption and how to optimize
the costs around electricity than
bitcoin no nothing has ever come maybe
car production or you know smelting
whatever the right term is in english
for for aluminum production which uses a
lot of energy
but i have learned more about the grid
of course i've always been a closet like
pro nuclear guy
uh and and i actually do think you're
going to see somebody bite the bullet
and develop small-scale nuclear reactors
explicitly for bitcoin and arbitrage you
know bitcoin that way
but what other space has gone this deep
and understanding how to optimize the
cost around energy none of course and i
do think that somebody is going to do
the nuclear if anyone wants to work on
that i would absolutely fund it if you
basically want to build these small
scale nuclear reactors totally and then
you use that to
hook up mining rigs and you mine it like
by far i think that is going to be a
solution but these next gen nuclear
reactors are so safe and i would love to
have them in our backyard in san jose
where years ago we had brownouts and
that's coming again with all the fires
and everything going on now now the the
progressives don't want to hear about it
but the truth is is that's the single
best solution that we have right now to
solving the energy problem that's why
bill gates has been putting money in
this stuff for 15 years yeah we we're
not allowed to talk about bill gates on
the show anymore we were told you know
he's got some crazy stuff going on
did you see the reason no
they like you know of course like once
you you're good there's a there's a
theory around uh everyone is the the
pirate right or like the challenger the
the upstart but you if you survive for
long enough you become the man right
which of course like uh i forget who
said it online one time but like bill
gates uh uh steve jobs like they would
all be working on this stuff today if
they were just starting out because they
used to be the challengers whatever but
eventually they got so big that they
just become complacent okay but what
happens when one of our
peeps in this space becomes the first
trillionaire based on crypto and they
become the men or the women for sure
gonna happen for sure gonna happen right
yeah but but the point being that so
that occurs and so what do people do now
you become a target and so what they do
they go back through all of his emails
and some of the stuff is like okay you
probably shouldn't have done that for
sure but then some of it's like stupid
stuff and what is it you just put bill
gates like anyone who's famous and rich
you put them in a headline like you get
clicks yeah and so i always go back to
like what is the incentive here uh and
unfortunately when you do that you
actually take away the true stories like
people don't pay attention as much
because like this is the 17th article
i've seen about bill gates you know in
the last week
the 17th one i'm probably not as excited
to click on as the first one even if the
17th one's more important because it's
just like you you get almost like uh uh
tired of seeing the same name in the
headline yeah well look i mean the
internet has been a great leveler in
terms of stopping old white guys from
doing creepy [ __ ]
you know
that one one of the recent reports was
around some emails i figured out where
you were headed with this but
yeah so yeah i mean kudos to to the
internet overlords for uh helping us
there i suppose so kevin i don't know if
we can hear him but literally i i can
see that kevin has a fake fish on a
screen behind where he's supposed to be
he's not but he's not there so i don't
know what he's doing but he's getting
set up uh hopefully uh he is uh not
gonna show up without pants on like we
had to ask yesterday scaramucci you got
pants on right now and he stood up and
showed us their pants o'leary may not
wear pants so you gotta always always
double check what do you guys think
about the nuclear power being used to uh
to mine bitcoin
i don't know i don't know much about uh
the process of it that's for sure i need
to learn more about that but i think um
one of the fascinating things and you
alluded to this is just like how
intensive people have had to study the
energy part of bitcoin and the mining
process has forced that right and i
think a lot of the flood that you hear
is just kind of those one-liners around
how much consumption there is and and uh
you know it's relative to other
countries and politicians love to throw
it out but when you actually look at the
numbers and nick carter did a great job
of this with the presentation uh that
you talked about earlier but the numbers
tell a completely different story right
so when you actually look into it and
you say like these guys are doing these
these uh men and women are doing the
work to understand kind of the energy
consumption side and how much of it's
being used uh and are really building
the infrastructure for an industry
that's going to be here for a long time
i agree with that john what do you think
yeah i definitely need to be more
educated on it but it uh it seems like a
possible thing also that energy can be
used for other things besides bitcoin so
just going down the uh the reactor point
of things is you can use it for many
many things and then the whole thought
around the bitcoin energy i think is
just ridiculous and it's been getting
disproved
time and time again and over time people
are starting to realize that it isn't
the most energy consuming industry and
there's tons of things that we can do
outside of that to what did you use what
did you call nick carter the flood
buster yeah he's a fun
the idea that that
open markets would create ultimately
a smart grid solution for this country
we effectively run a dumb grid we don't
run a grid in the united states right
other countries have leapfrogged us in
terms of creating that smart grid
how great would it be if it was
ultimately the free markets that
incentivized us to have not only these
nuclear plants small path you know
small-scale plants but have smart grids
that could route
based upon market demand at any given
time meaning if there was peak demand uh
you know in summer and you could route
to people's homes because the price was
higher and it was more efficient to do
that then do it right and in in lower
demand times when you could route and
use it for for bitcoin mining
why not right so so
it's it's the opposite of what the
powers that be would have us think again
they've gotten it 100
wrong 100 of the time when it comes to
bitcoin you know i i still
i i can't believe that i you know the
ted cruz uh comment that
you know we're we're regulating things
we simply don't understand and i'm kudos
to him for even saying it that's why i
was shocked that he would admit it um
but it's true all right and and as
somebody who seems to get energy um you
know we've got it completely wrong with
bitcoin all right i think we have kevin
okay let's pull him up are you there
i'm here can you hear me
i can hear you yes all right do you have
pants on
no pants
[Laughter]
all right great start great start uh i
want to talk to you about a whole bunch
of stuff you got me two of my brothers
and bill barhat from uh abra here first
i want to start with the big news of the
bitcoin etf what's your read on the
launch of the bitcoin etf and the impact
on the market
i like it
as an indicator that the regulator is
warming up to finally
providing guidance and regulation
for the real thing i don't like it as a
product
if i'm going to be exposed to the price
of bitcoin why don't i just buy bitcoin
and so the futures market is very
efficient but sometimes when prices are
very volatile not so much and so look
it's great that it's happened it's
clearly reflected in the overall price
of bitcoin with the optimism globally
that the us regulator is finally going
to get behind cryptocurrencies not just
bitcoin and it's a first baby step but
frankly you can buy an etf with the real
thing underlying up in canada right now
and other countries are doing that even
with ethereum now in canada so you know
hopefully within 24 months which is sort
of my time view we're going to have the
real thing bitcoin inside an etf wrapper
that allows people with equity
portfolios to buy it and get price
exposure to the price of bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies it's not a bad thing
you can't say it's bad but it's not the
way i i don't want to invest in it that
way and why pay the fees why don't you
just buy bitcoin and hold it in a
decentralized wallet and i think that's
the most efficient way to do it what are
the institutions saying to you about the
etf is this kind of like an open the
kimono now they think that they can
start to allocate to the uh asset
because there's an etf approved
no
no this doesn't it still hasn't been the
majority of institutions and the wire
houses that run the very large brokerage
community
are not there yet this has not been
approved by compliance just the fact
that it's a futures contract in itself
just futures contracts are for
accredited investors only anyways so
it's a small subset to start off with
and they can buy it on their own in an
online account but the major houses have
not approved this yet
okay when we think about monetary policy
the fed actions and uh kind of inflation
talk to me about your view right now
we've now had multiple months of over
five percent cpi core inflation's at
four percent uh and we continue to get
this idea of a lot of people saying it's
all transitory how do you think about
inflation and then also what the fed's
actions should be moving forward
so
i spend a lot of time on this model
because it's reflected in my operating
costs in the 34 private companies that i
own
everything from gym equipment
manufacturers to commercial kitchens
insecticide companies this is how broad
the portfolio is what is happening right
now is supply chain issues and it's
reflected in what i call transitory
inflation let me give you an example i
can't get parts off a ship that's moored
outside of los angeles for six days i
just found that out before i came on the
air because it's stuck in a jam trying
to get into the port we're not operating
the la port 24 7 which is insane in
itself but because i can't get those
parts i'm scrambling to buy parts so i
can finish off manufacturing equipment
and i'm paying up as much as 30 percent
to find those parts in the secondary
market that is reflected as an
inflationary increase in my cost of
goods it's happening all through the s p
500 so the fact that we can't get our
logistics figured out is the reason we
have inflation right now in every aspect
of business the same thing in trying to
move you know operations out of staffing
facilities we have in china to vietnam
just to move the the molds i can't even
get a container it's four times more
expensive than it was just 18 months ago
to get a container to move the equipment
so inflation is a result of broken down
supply side logistics when we think
about those supply chain disruptions how
much of it is initiated by the fact that
people were handed money they started to
spend that money in the economy they
drove up demand and the supply chains
weren't ready for the demand and that
ultimately broke the supply chains which
then leads to the increased prices or is
it just not the supply chains coming out
of kovid they kind of got shut off then
turned back on and it's the turning back
on that's actually breaking them
well you're right the consumer never
turned off even in the height of of
covet you know february march april last
year when it was just you know a huge
pandemic they still had those stimulus
checks and they were still ordering
everything online and so the the amount
of traffic that started direct to
consumer really put pressure on
logistics for transportation both in
inbound goods in the u.s and then
distributing those goods within major
metropolitan areas and it never stopped
it just kept growing and growing and
growing i'll give you an example nike
you know a behemoth global company
in five months got to 50 direct to
consumer they thought it was going to
take them six years and that's the good
news the bad news is the amount of
logistics you need to be able to ship
sneakers all over the world whether it's
phnom penh cambodia or new york city put
tremendous pressure on the systems in
place and so we have got this remarkable
situation now with huge consumer demand
six seven eight nine percent gdp growth
and we don't have the infrastructure to
support it and i'll give you another
case or use case where it's a big
problem that i'm dealing with now chip
shortages we only make 25 of
semiconductors in the global demand here
in the united states the other 75 is in
asia we can't get the chips i don't care
if it's a truck you're trying to buy
from ford or something from me and
consumer electronics i cannot get the
supply how did that happen to us how is
that possible it's not about just in
time inventory we need just in case
inventory in case demand is stripping
what we thought it was going to be which
is exactly what's happening right now
so one of the uh repercussions of this
is as we get higher levels of inflation
uh obviously all the people who are
holding fixed income whether it's pimco
or some of the other really large uh
fixed income asset managers but also the
pension funds the endowments the
foundations the really large asset
allocators that uh depend on this stuff
as part of a large portion of their
portfolio they now all seem to really be
struggling and the reason why they're
struggling is just because on a real
return basis they're now returning
negative on that fixed income and so
what are you seeing there as like a
repercussion of the higher inflation and
how people are thinking about their
portfolios
it's a huge problem it is a massive
problem because the traditional
allocation to an institutional portfolio
was 60 equity 40 fixed income generally
that fixed income in a foreign uh form
of a ladder of government bonds average
duration maybe nine years and corporate
credits will be in about five to seven
year duration and they would always pay
you two to three hundred basis points
over inflation that's not the case today
there's lots of corporate paper being
issued right now under three percent for
five to seven year duration when
inflation is 2.1 percent the real return
is is is almost zero in terms of buying
power and so that's incredibly risky and
it's one of the reasons you've seen such
an incredible demand or interest in
stable coins that can be staked out at
five six seven percent for 30 60 90 days
and that's got the regulator really um i
wouldn't say upset but concerned stable
coins have become the focus of the
regulator right now because people are
treating like money markets and in some
cases they may not be that
what do you think happens there with
those stable coins
so you're well aware of the tether
situation you know that circle has uh
started with you know just two years ago
practically nothing in usdc and now is
over 30 billion dollars that's a lot of
money and most of that is in the hands
of high net worth individuals family
offices hedge funds it is not yet
approved institutionally for reasons we
already know the regulator is
scrutinizing it
i think the genies out of the bottle or
the ship has sailed or whatever analogy
you want to use we're not
it's it's not going to be made illegal
it's going to be regulated now how much
balance sheet assets you need to support
your stablecoin is going to be the
debate and frankly i think the smart
move is being done by the ceo jeremy at
circle by simply saying to the regulator
turn me into a bank regulate me like a
bank because that's what i am i'm being
treated like a bank by my investors and
once that happens and if it does i think
that's a really good first step because
you know i think it's easier to regulate
stable coins backed by usd
or whatever you know short term jurassic
duration government credit
and and get that through the meat
grinder of the regulator than it is
bitcoin which is so controversial for
all the reasons you've been talking
about for years so if i saw that happen
first
that would be great it would be a good
step forward and then then the debate
about decentralized finance and
financing and payment systems that'll
come into focus next there's just so
much going on it's it's incredible right
now so circle is uh let's just refer to
them as kind of a private market
participant that's doing this other
private market participants would be the
large banks we know jp morgan tried to
launch jpm coin there's a couple of
others that have tried stuff uh how do
you think about the private market doing
this versus let's say the united states
with like a central bank digital
currency or or some sort of state-backed
effort
i don't think they're entrepreneurial
enough to pull it off i really don't um
what what what happened in circle
if you meet that management team as i
have uh
these are very very um savvy
entrepreneurs that are working within
the crypto community with their version
of what a stablecoin is they moved very
very quickly they had you know virtually
nothing under management just 24 months
ago and now we're past
23 24 25 billion and it's going up every
week
you don't see that in the traditional
banking system because
they're trying to protect their own
systems that they have already in place
they don't want to cannibalize
themselves and frankly if they were
successful in launching a stable coin
they would have to do it under their own
compliance systems which
and the and those compliance officers in
a giant wire house know that the
regulator is scrutinizing
all of the players in crypto in stable
points and they're going to wait till
there's a judgment they're not going to
go and start fighting with the regulator
and a jp morgan that's not going to
happen
and so this is a really interesting
story of the hair and the turtle you
know that starting very slowly
sometimes you can win but maybe not in
crypto once you get scale once you
become a standard once everybody's using
your platform and writing and you know
staking and loaning and doing it as
i'm doing that right now at circle i'm
putting out contracts of 30 60 90 days
on usdc i go to fiat usdc i get paid
back in usdc and i can convert back to
fee in any currency but to get that
through my own auditor took me six
months
let alone that's getting them to agree
to sign the statement so i can file with
the regulator i mean this is going to
take a while how much are you earning
when you do some of this stuff like what
are their general rates and what i'm
trying to compare it to is like the
fixed income guys who were earning you
know five six uh seven percent on their
like highest risk stuff lower risk stuff
was kind of you know one two percent
what is it in the stable coin world
right now
well
each platform's different right now you
see some very attractive rates on ftx if
you if you're able to set up an account
and you have compliance i'll let you do
that including their own compliance
which is very heavy scrutiny
they make sure it comes on that platform
whatever geography they're in
remain compliant with their own law you
know code in whether switzerland or
france or canada whatever
you can do more than seven percent on
ftx right now and staking
circle contracts right now yesterday i
did some at 6.2 percent for 90 days
that's very attractive on usdc so you're
you're beating inflation you do have
regulatory risk i mean if tomorrow
morning i wake up and usdc is no longer
allowed by the regulator that ain't good
news and so that's why there's some
hesitancy but you know we have as a
weighting probably less than one percent
in the particular mandate in usdc right
now but i would take it up way bigger if
the regulator would let me and and i
would probably have i'd put our cash in
there you know it could be 20
and because i don't want to make 22
basis points that's what my cash desk is
giving me right now 22 basis points when
inflation is 2.1
yeah it's crazy uh you now are mr
wonderful your world famous abc shark
tank i see you smile when i say it if
there's humans on mars they know who you
are uh so this isn't just like a uh
western hemisphere conversation right
it's not just about the united states
and canada i know that you've got a
number of different friends colleagues
and peers all throughout the middle east
europe what are they all saying about
this are they jumping in the game are
they still a little bit uh hesitant
what's the international money doing
it's very very interesting the topic
that's going to be in riyadh next week
is about crypto and there's a tremendous
amount of excitement about it but they
have not pulled the trigger yet they're
trying to get themselves set up for the
moment when the regulator allows it both
in their own geography and in the u.s
you got to remember that those those
funds those those sovereign funds
whether it be in saudi arabia or united
arab emirates a huge amount of that
capital is invested in the s p 500 and
derivatives thereof
huge amounts huge huge amounts so they
cannot be offside with the u.s regulator
they just can't and so and i look at
this as a huge opportunity i speak to
those guys almost every day
they would immediately go to one to
three percent on bitcoin alone just
bitcoin let alone ethereum or any level
one level twos
on the chain they haven't even thought
about that they're just thinking about
bitcoin and and owning that as an asset
the amount of capital that will come
into this market
when the regulator approves bitcoin as
an asset or currency or a security
whatever they're going to
you know regulate it as is going to be
unbelievable which is why i own it i
mean
my premise you know stomaching the
volatility which we all do every
12-month cycle
is the upside is behemoth is huge and so
you know whether it be for me it's an
asset it's a long-term hold the coin i
own the coin is the coin i own i don't
trade it i lend it i stake it
and you know i get some income from that
but i'm never going to give up the coin
and you know i heard you guys talking
about the the esg issue i'm sorry that
hasn't gone away but there have been
some new initiatives in raising capital
to solve for it so before we get to the
esg stuff with this international money
right you you talk about them wanting to
go one to three percent just to bitcoin
maybe they would do some other stuff as
well are we talking about just large
family offices in the middle east and
europe are we talking about uh
foundations sovereign wealth funds like
and i'm trying to use that as a proxy
for like how serious uh the most
conservative investors in the world are
about this versus oh this is a large
family office where there's kind of one
decision maker and they're going to end
up making that decision based on how
comfortable they are on a regulation
standpoint and also a return standpoint
yeah um
the the real opportunity is not with the
family offices or hedge funds that
operate out of the middle east
the real money is in the actual
sovereign funds
in both saudi arabia and the united arab
emirates
it's billions and billions and billions
of dollars they have not allocated to
crypto yet
when that happens
you'll see it reflected in the price of
bitcoin there's no question about it and
they have such long-term views in those
funds
that and the funds are so large
remember
these countries don't operate the same
way as the u.s domestic countries do
although they're managed many of the
people managing
those middle eastern funds to sovereign
funds are actually western educated
managers and so they generally abide by
discipline and principles of
uh
you know
risk diversification so they may have a
mandate for example that no stock can
represent more than five percent of the
fund or those sector more than 20
those are diversification mandates that
are used all around the world and they
do that there too
but when you're dealing with a
multi-billion dollar mandate
and some of these are
they're the largest pools of capital in
the world a one percent allocation
is a tremendous amount of money and so
there's a whole bunch of people and me
included heading over in november um and
everybody is talking about not just
bitcoin anymore it's what would a
portfolio look like
if
you know the managers are asking this of
participants that are already building
these portfolios give me an allocation
of positions if i want to be exposed to
bitcoin itself of course but also be
involved in decentralized finance and
also own level 1 and level 2 chains what
does that look like
and i'm heading over i think probably
you and i at some point in the next few
weeks i'm going to give you
my portfolio i'm not finished yet but
it's over 21 positions right now and
i'll i'll do it on your show i'll
disclose what i own i think you're going
to be knocked out but you see what i've
got here because i've gone right down
the rabbit hole i've hired multiple
people uh to do the due diligence on
some of these really eclectic projects
but we are investing in them
my last question on let's say the
sovereign wealth funds is could you see
them getting into mining at some point
yeah great question and yes that is my
plan and here's the that goes to the esg
issue okay here's the solution all right
let's say you can't get a rent your
compliance department can't get around
the issue of esg because it's still out
there and there still have compliance uh
and and ethics committees and these big
funds and so here's a solution let's say
you go from scratch let's say you go to
west texas and you want to build a gig
facility and build it out in 250
increments and you and you basically
guarantee the investors that you're only
going to use wind and solar and you
agree to the texas grid that you'll pay
back
some of your production
and you go to the capital markets and
say
every time we're awarded a coin it stays
on the balance sheet of this investment
so you know with certainty that your
coin was mined in this facility that you
won't
that's what i'm doing and that's a big
solution for me because i i get to check
the box now
on esg for anybody that's you know even
saying to me where does your coin come
from i can't do that if i buy an etf i
can't do that if i just go and buy a
coin in the open market but i can do
that if i was awarded the coin in an esd
compliant facility and there's enough
coin to be mined left that you're going
to see a lot of capital put to work and
not just the geography in west texas
there's other jurisdictions in northern
europe that are looking at this proposal
as well so you're basically going into
the government office saying we are
going to mine sustainable we're going to
do it
give us the permits give us access to
the grids give us all the things we need
to be able to service this facility and
let us get to work so i've got bill from
abra here what's your take on the esg
stuff
well uh kevin really great to meet you
uh very impressed with how deep you've
gone on this topic uh it's not easy so
much respect there
um i guess
you know two questions right first i
understand that the esg issue hasn't
quote unquote gone away
but
one do the numbers really support the
narrative when you go deep that the
issue
should exist
and do you actually think that you could
produce enough energy in wind and solar
at large scale to make a dent
uh in the hash power war assuming that
we get back to the current
uh hash power numbers by this time next
year actually i'm assuming we would be
ahead of the
the
pre-china crackdown numbers by this time
next year and would wind in solar
actually make enough of a dent to even
warrant the investment
it's a great question you can't do it
with solar alone it's a combination of
wind and solar which makes it expensive
but it's definitely it's g compliant and
and let me tell you
i agree with you around the debate i
mean if you want to own bitcoin own
bitcoin but it's it's not that simple if
you have a compliance department and you
have the larry fink letter hanging over
you everybody knows about the larry
think letter in fact everybody also
knows that blackrock has hired a chief
esg
officer and so if you are being serviced
by and every sovereign fund in the world
works with blackrock pretty well
you really can't go against that mandate
it's not going to work for you you've
got to solve it and so the question is
you got to check the box on esg or you
can't play in the coin space if you're
tied into those metrics so it's not like
they don't want to
it's they can't it's the same issue
about you know buying certain goods and
services from banned countries um that's
what the ethics committee stopped you
there too i i really i really work in
this in this in this institutional world
and
it's not like you can call up the chief
compliance officer and have a dialogue
regarding the merits of mining bitcoin
with existing energy sources
they just don't give a [ __ ] they're not
going to take the call they're just
saying no so when they see how much
money is being made in the space don't
you think they're just going to change
the narrative to fit what they need it
to be to make the investment which is
what i mean come on they do that anyway
i mean and also they're not eliminating
all the companies from the fortune 500
that probably wouldn't pass muster on
the same usage around esg
uh if they weren't already in the
portfolio today
well that's not true actually if you
look at the allocations even calpers
alone said this after the think letter
they're going to downsize their energy
holdings
but probably you're up at 20 percent
they may be down as low as eight now and
you can see it reflected in large enemy
energy names like
uh you know schlumberger and exxon and
mobile
they're they're they're getting their
pes compressed because the incremental
buyer is not there anymore
on the high on the hydrocarbon mandate
coming out of the white house so there's
some pretty big uh forces at play and
when you talk about you know if you only
own bitcoin at 8 000 now it's over 60
000 to it to a sovereign fund that's
running you know 30 40 50 60 billion
dollars it's a rounding error
they don't care and
and it's the same time it's the greatest
opportunity for those of us that have
invested in cryptocurrencies is to solve
this problem for them
i mean
it's not going to get solved
debating it with the compliance officer
it's going to get solved when they can
simply check the box saying this
facility in norway this facility in
northern quebec this facility in
northern alberta and this facility in
west texas where the places i'm looking
at
mine sustainably as agreed to with the
government the government has
certified this an est compliant facility
then then the debate's over in fact
those are the very people that i'm going
to to raise capital from to build out
these facilities because it solves their
problem the same compliance office that
won't let the fund buy bitcoin will put
money in the ground to build a facility
to to to minecoin if it's csg compliant
go fair
joe john what questions you guys got hey
kevin thanks for doing this nice to see
you again uh so i remember seeing
something that you said i think it was a
month or two ago that you were going to
double your crypto exposure in your
portfolio is this something that you're
actively looking to do is this something
that you're waiting on uh regulation for
or have you already done it et cetera
just a little more kind of insight into
that
no i'm on my way by the end of december
i should be at seven percent of the
operating companies portfolio and the
way i'm doing it is with ftx i i became
an investor uh
this week in ftx it's a private company
but i was able to buy some of it because
i've become their paid spokesperson most
people know that
right beside tom brady i love that
i can't wait to play some football with
you but the bottom line is they're smart
about it
they're helping me build that portfolio
with some very eclectic products
that normally it's not easy to get
access to i'm really fascinated now
by the different approaches
on decentralized ledgers and so i've got
a lot of people on my team working on it
i think the nft market is going to be
absolutely huge and i'm going to be a
participant in it and i'm thinking nfts
not just on digital art
i'm thinking nft is used to authenticate
physical assets the one i'm working on
because i'm a huge watch collector and i
know all the world's largest collectors
and the ceos of all the watch companies
is authenticating secondary market watch
training
i don't know if you saw that article
last week i think it was put out by cnbc
20 billion dollars a year of trading in
the watch asset class and the biggest
problem let's say i want to buy patek
philippe that went off the market 17
years ago which i'm doing right now
a piece celebrating their 75th
anniversary i have to send it to a guy
named john reardon in new york to get it
authenticated to know that it's real
the hassle of doing that the cost of
doing that moving it from the the seller
in hong kong to new york city and bond
having john look at it open up make sure
it's real close and send it back to the
seller so it's in his physical hands
then do the trade
i could avoid all that with a watch nft
if once that watch was put on the market
it was
reardon would do an nft to it approve it
certify it and for the rest of that
watch is life and every time it trades
you know it's real and if we have to pay
back a royalty to protect philippe
wherever the maker is or the designer of
the dial that's fine you can all do that
on smart contract so should that be on
solana should that be on ethereum should
be on a derivative of theorem i don't
know yet that's the worst which that's
the research i'm working on john what
questions you got yeah what's up kevin i
see you again um can you talk more about
your stable coin holdings and like any
restrictions that you have what coins
you like versus other ones
yeah
um
i've done a lot of work on stablecoin
because uh this was out of need about 18
months ago we took down our commercial
real estate holdings including here in
boston where i am
down from 31 of the operating companies
portfolio remember these are income
producing properties so it's a form of
our way we made income and the cap rates
got so low here in boston new york
detroit miami we just sold it including
you know climate controlled storage
facilities that we bought at 11 cap that
were trading at three and a half cap so
it was time to exit so we sold it down
to eight percent holdings the only
buildings we didn't sell are liquid or
have you know issues around them that
they house movie theaters and things
like that
and we had all this cash so we go to the
cash desk and we say okay we have to
park this cash while we redeploy it
and they offered us 23 basis points and
i'm talking about some of the biggest
cash chests in new york and i said this
is insane you're going to give me 23
biffs and and i'm you know i'm facing
2.1 inflation
that's when we started digging into
stablecoin because that was the first
time we started that dialogue with
circle and other entities
and then i called up our auditors and
said look we're going to deploy some of
this cash into stable coins and we chose
usdc because we really like the
compliance
team over at circle if you really those
guys understand our problems regarding
compliance and the audit said i said no
way no way you are not doing that we're
not signing uh that the statements i
said that's crazy like you i want to
deploy this capital you won't sign my
status no we won't it's not it's not
approved by the regulator
i mean
guys you know
we talk about crypto collectively all
day long but
it is so early in the institutional
world it is so nascent it's so
not there yet and that in itself is the
giant opportunity i mean just stable
coins alone
would be a huge market if you could
actually lend them out even anything
over four percent i assume when they
when they regulate it the demand is
going to be so high it's going to push
down the yields but right now you're
talking 6.2
on a 90 day
you know statement which is phenomenal
unless you wake up and the regulator
changed their minds on unstable coins in
usdc which is kind of scary which is why
we can't load up we can do you know
maybe 100 basis points worth of it but
we can't put 20 of a portfolio into it i
would if it was regulated so and i'm
just one guy can you imagine what would
happen if it tomorrow morning regulator
says okay here are the rules for stable
coins here's what a stable coin money
market fund looks like yeah you have to
be a bank and then circle turns into a
bank whatever is going to happen i'm
speculating when i say that but the
demand would be unbelievable
kevin i got two questions for you and
then we'll let you go first is when you
think about uh those regulators coming
in and giving the thumbs up kind of uh
saying all right everyone go
would you go to 20 or would you do more
in your portfolio in terms of full
exposure to the industry could you see
yourself going to 50 plus percent given
that you're 50 plus percent in u.s
dollar
kind of assets and cash
well
you know it's a good question paul
and we just had that discussion uh on
monday with our ot
here's here's what i think we're gonna
do we're gonna go to seven percent on
crypto itself by december but i've also
started to take some pretty big
positions in public minors right now
that are checking the box on esg
and so i guess you could argue that if
you included that in what we'll call the
crypto weighting if you want to call
that an asset class
and the reason i'm doing it that way is
i really can't go past 20 in any one
sector if you call
i really believe
that that crypto is the 12th sector of
the s p we don't know it yet it hasn't
been designated that but it's coming in
in the years ahead we have 11 sectors
now including real estate crypto is
going to be number 12 primarily driven
by decentralized finance it's so
disruptive so powerful so productive
it'll get there so i want to have more
exposure during that transition um
and i guess the way to do that and and
keep my own compliance department on
board my own auditor on board is to
simply buy
the securities of those compliant miners
that are trading with the volatility of
bitcoin's pricing
and i think that will get you know i'm
going to be discussing this in in uh in
abu dhabi in november and i'll present
the portfolio there same thing in the
same arrests there's a huge conference
there in switzerland in january about
this exact topic that you're raising
this exact topic
very high net worth individuals and
family offices in europe are i guess
it's not a secret anymore but
it's happening and and a lot of the
crypto players are going to be there
presenting their their way of indexing
crypto i'll show mine i'll listen to
everybody else's
um
i i bet you i'm spending 40 of my day
now on this on this topic maybe even 50
because it's performing so well
i mean i don't have anything performing
this well so
my prediction
back in 2018 the first time you and i
ever went on television i said yeah i'm
gonna remind you you forbid me for being
over 50
why are you such a dick about this
but here's my prediction is that in the
next five years more than 50 of your
portfolio will be in but not from a
sense of i know you have these 20 kind
of limitations but i think what'll end
up happening is your let's say real
estate portfolio people will start
paying you in stable coins so it'll be
kind of tangential or indirectly related
to it and so you'll have exposure in
more than 50 of the portfolio to these
technologies it's just not going to be
50 plus percent of you going and buying
bitcoin or you know one of the
individual assets themselves
yeah i i think you might be right on
that i'll tell you where i think it's
going to manifest itself first in the fx
market for example i use this example
all the time i have a portfolio of over
50
names in europe uh large cap stocks
trading in zurich in europe and in
london so they've got british pounds you
got euros you got swiss francs every
time i put on the position i have to go
usd
i have to go through an fx desk pay bips
convert to swiss francs buy the local
market when i sell the position it goes
in reverse so i'm getting clipped lots
of basis points a lot of friction there
i think when the regulators approve a a
payment system on the chain between a
market like the swiss market in the us
market uh that solves the problem
forever
i mean you're right because when i when
i buy that security i'll buy it
on a chain
in a in a way that i don't have to go
through multiple fields and
i think that's going to happen within
five years and so you're right people
are going to be exposed to crypto and
payment systems that'll represent 40 50
60 70 of their net worth they just won't
think of it that way it's a good it's a
good analogy correct my last question
for you is uh when you guys were doing
the filming for shark tank i think you
recently did that over the last few
months what's the conversation behind
closed doors uh you mark lori barbara
robert the whole crew what are most
people uh saying about this are they all
as bullish as you are or there's still
uh some skepticism uh among that uh
crowd and i use them as a proxy for most
of kind of uh uh the average american
that is one of their biggest sources of
kind of business content is watching
shark tank so what's the thought process
of
of your co-host
well you know we don't do crypto deals
on shark tank or marijuana we don't you
can't do those for for because
of regulatory reasons and we we're also
very very sensitive to the regulator for
obvious reasons for you know it's a
network uh owned by disney etc
but behind closed doors um
mark and i are very very active in
crypto you know the cubit is uh we we
share notes on nfts
um
you know
i'm i'm intrigued by that whole uh
business and i'm very active in that
i've i've invested in wonderful
you know which is decentralized finance
um they're bringing their app in the
next few weeks the company just raised
another 20 million yesterday
also in jordan freed's business the
platform called immutable holdings he
owns nft.com he's setting up profiles
for most of the s p 500 brands i'm
working with him on the watch industry
for example i own a piece of that
company too
uh
and and you know i look at all these
i look at this stuff probably of the
sharks two uh two out of us
are are allocated portfolios to it the
others not so much yet but they're very
interested
they're more traditional in how they
deploy capital but
i don't know how you
how you can ignore it anymore
um given the pressures that you started
this conversation with around inflation
and you know decentralized finance the
productivity can provide the economy
you just can't ignore it and i
understand the regulatory cloud i get it
but i don't think even the regulators
want to abandon the promise that crypto
has for the american economy it just has
to be
rules-based and they'll get there
eventually even if it takes time
that's where we're at so the sharks that
are not yet allocating is this basically
a question around regulatory or is it
they're not yet convinced or what is
kind of the biggest um critique or the
biggest obstacle that you see
turning them from uh not being allocated
to actually getting allocated
primarily regulatory i mean you know
without naming any specific shark they
all have big brands they all support all
kinds of companies some of them have
their own products goods and services
around their name
and it's it's the same reason that they
don't
they don't get involved in the cannabis
market it's a schedule one regulated
narcotic in multiple states and yet it's
legal in others but
they they they have to be compliant and
so
any they all have advisors and
you know it's like i said earlier i have
to fight my auditors i have to say no no
no no you don't get it they say we get
it and the answer is no
and so
it takes a fair amount of
energy to pursue this when all the
advisors around you are saying no and
won't even support you
i mean
that's
that's really
the truth about what what crypto is now
it's it's a growing
it was a baby five years ago now it's a
teenager and it's nasty because it's not
stopping it's gonna keep going and it's
gonna be an adult soon and those teenage
years are a [ __ ] that's the problem
i know you well enough that all you need
to do is when you talk to the other
sharks say listen i believe in it so
much i got my own dough in it and when
you say that they'll obviously
understand that uh if you're comfortable
they should be they know they know and
everybody's interested to see what my
holdings are i get that every day you
know what i'm really worried about i
don't want to be one of these guys that
you know get some obscure token or coin
and promotes it and you know all that
stuff i don't want to be seen that way
i'm being very careful to make these
long-term investments because i believe
in you know the best way to look at this
and i tell people this that really grill
me on crypto and particularly when that
you keep floating that video of us
together on cnbc you know on twitter and
i get abused over and over again i'm
never going to forgive you that i'm
going to figure a way to get you back i
don't know how i'm gonna figure it out
but what i tell them is
look
do you invest in google do you invest in
microsoft those are big holdings for me
they are software companies when you
invest in crypto and the blockchain and
the level one level two ideas out there
and a lot of these tokens and a lot of
these shared ledgers you're investing in
software why would you invest in
microsoft and not in the chain
why
why wouldn't you and they said well i
never thought of it that way well think
about it that way because that's what it
is you're just adding to your software
productivity portfolio now i get it it's
controversial and all the rest of it but
the innovation that's occurring
by these developers the hottest hands on
the keyboard are now in crypto the
smartest guys
are doing this work and you're getting
engineers are leaving traditional
productivity software like crazy to go
into crypto whether it's a startup or
work with a behemoth or whatever it is
because the productivity
opportunities there are greater than
anything else we have in software and so
you know i just gave you the use case
for watches it's for every asset class
it's all coming but it's all software
so the politicians that say shadowy
supercoders kevin says the hottest hands
are on the keyboard i like that that's a
much better way to put it i think
yeah well i mean look politicians have
to make press
uh they're constantly raising capital
for their own campaigns i understand the
pressure they're under nothing gets you
more press the two ways to get press
these days is beat up facebook which
always works to get you on the hill
which is ludicrous because they're the
backbone of small business in america
and talk about crypto as being used for
crime that's going to get you a lot of
headlines that's going to help you raise
a lot of money it's never going to stop
but that's not what crypto's about
anymore decentralized finance is going
to be very disruptive very powerful very
productive
it's going to eliminate a lot of fees
and it's going to make life a lot easier
for everybody like me when i talked
about trying to buy and sell european
stocks in multiple currencies
i mean why wouldn't i invest in that of
course all right where do you want us to
send people you can go follow you on
twitter where else
um come and look at my uh i'm doing a
lot of this stuff on youtube so you know
mr monofall on youtube good place to go
i discuss this every week practically
and linkedin also doing a lot of white
papers on there
um there's a lot of interest on linkedin
which is you know primarily managers in
what's going on in crypto
um so
i i think that i think the genie is out
of the bottle now and this is going to
be forever a debate um and you know
kudos for you for bringing it out early
on and becoming a you know
marching to that tune when everybody
thought it was crazy including me
but you know when things change i change
and things have changed
i always tell people i said listen i've
got one clip i'ma play it forever but
after that you eventually changed your
mind and uh and the thing that i will
give you a lot of credit for which i
don't think people really uh understand
is it's one thing to change your mind
right you can go from hey i don't like
this okay now i'm okay with it but it's
another thing to sound it's not just
going to be half a percent or one
percent right you're talking about going
to seven percent eventually maybe 20
percent like it's it's uh going from
being a a critic or a uh having
critiques to now saying no hold on a
second not only do i like this but i'm
going to press the winners right i'm
going to go in because that's where i'm
actually spending 40 50 of my time
that's where a big portion of my
portfolio goes and i think a lot of
people they they get caught up in uh not
having the intellectual flexibility they
already were against it and now when
they say okay fine i like it a little
bit they don't want to be seen as going
all in on it right becoming a big
proponent which you've obviously done so
i i will forever always respect you for
changing your mind which i think uh most
people they can give you [ __ ] on twitter
i'm going to keep inciting that but
other than that
you're good at my book
well look i really appreciate it great
talking to you guys take care and i'm
sure we'll get together again soon all
right sounds good talk soon
bye-bye
he doesn't like the clip
that's all right that's right uh he
doesn't have pants on either for sure
i don't know bill if you've ever seen i
haven't uh one of the things i love
about kevin is he's just hey this is who
i am whatever so he'll uh have somebody
take a photo when he's like on cnbc and
he'll have on like uh almost like swim
short uh things like flowers on him and
stuff but have the suit and and the the
tie on and so he'll look all serious
he's got like shorts and sandals i'll
stick with your description of the
visual yeah
he always has on shorts just not paying
yeah hey you got to give him credit man
the 180 he's done and and i was going to
say i think he's going to be at 50 in
crypto just from the gains that he's
going to be of course if he gets to 20
and just all he has to do is wait at
that point he's going to be 50
what do you guys think about uh about
kevin now i like him i think he's cool i
think uh he's obviously gone down the
rabbit hole he's looking at a bunch of
different things right from from
different tokens and nft products and
platforms and businesses that he can
invest in uh but it's cool i think it's
funny looking back at the clip and
seeing just like how far he's come from
totally dismissing it calling people
crazy and all this stuff to now he's
he's you know saying i'm gonna double my
investment and put seven percent of my
entire portfolio into it
i love it we're at 3.7 k likes john you
ready to pick somebody yeah on the
camera for the fact of i'm a big fan of
if you're a bitcoin
bear like the bitcoin bulls should
embrace you when you switch over that
hump 100 should get involved in it open
arms kevin
welcome all right we're at 3.7 k likes
on the count of three one two three
press the like button everybody all at
once we cross over 4k
what should we do do like uh 150 bucks
again
well joe's paying so what do you want to
give joe
uh yeah 150 is good
but it was my day to give i was giving a
thousand dollars oh no no no you weren't
i i'm pretty sure people got a thousand
dollars
yeah all right all you got to do to
finish the show
is
leave in the chat your twitter account
oh there you go 4k likes leaving the
chat your twitter account and also what
your favorite moment in the show that
was part of john or related to john that
involved john look at this smile
what was your favorite part of the show
that incorporates john uh and leave your
twitter account and john will pick one
nice someone said i'm sweating
the money's already going out there's no
sweating all right someone's getting
picked
your favorite moment of the show that
included john and also what was your
favorite movement of the show that
included me i i actually liked you're
gonna think this is funny i actually
liked when i was uh in los angeles
and i was uh looking through my laptop
watching you guys do the show without me
and i was in the chat and i saw joe up
here being an absolute fool with the
fire pomp shirts and i looked over and i
was wearing a shirt too i don't know but
john was like this i could see it in
john's face john i don't want to wear
this shirt they made me wear this shirt
i don't want to wear this no i wanted to
wear the shirt
all right who are you picking all right
wait before we get to that let's let a
couple people get their answers in uh i
have a a service announcement here uh
people were asking earlier how you can
join the union all right so stop phil i
don't know i don't know if you've heard
about this but we have a union i i think
you're in it now
basically it's against him and we you
know we pay our dues in bitcoin and we
do all this stuff and who keeps the
dudes who's going to say what john and i
are co-heads uh we let them out and we
collect well
bill you came in so you're good on the
dues there's no dues needed from you uh
but you're in the union first rule of
the union is don't give special favors
to anybody because then everybody are
unions especially we don't follow all
the general rules uh but we have bitcoin
on our balance sheet you know that's the
way we operate around here and uh people
were asking earlier how they can join
all you gotta ask is just ask you're in
you're in regardless we're eventually
going to have some uh some membership
stuff here but uh you're in you guys
keep telling me a number of people that
are in the union
things been growing every single day and
i are keeping track we got like 75 guys
messaging us on linkedin saying how do i
join
we got like 75 bill 76 we're good to go
just pick a winner let's go i got one
someone ciao ahmeda
amita how do you spell it john hoddle
he's in chaos
yeah all right you want to say anything
did what they said and john smile i
appreciate it thank you for watching the
show you picked somebody because they
said you're
you're done from picking what do you
mean it had nothing to do with what they
said i just picked a random person and
then i looked at the comment and it
happened to comment about my smile
all right we appreciate you guys
watching everybody you just got 10 more
members make sure
make sure that you go ahead and uh and
like the video make sure you subscribe
to the channel we appreciate bill coming
on today uh from abra where can we send
people for uh to check out oprah
abbott.com i'm on twitter billbarhite
follow me there right there you didn't
even see we got your twitter account
ready to rock and roll uh we appreciate
kevin coming on and uh we will uh
we will see you guys tomorrow by the way
i texted o'leary when he was late and i
said you're live over there and he still
hasn't read it because he has read
receipts on so i don't know what he's
doing he's got receipts on yeah so do
you all right we'll see you guys
tomorrow
[Music]
you